hot breath what do you feel is the
biggest drawback that keeps the bigger
distributors from buying specials
[Music]
well i'll tell you what netflix told me
okay they said we got a lot of honkies
a lot of straight whitey but if you're
selling out
like 2 000 seats or more we'll have you
because that means they can guarantee
views so be
a minority get in a wheelchair
be fat have something
uh or get famous and then go and become
a stand-up
um or just get a following if you get a
following on your own it becomes some
youtube queef
that'll help you know go get a huge
youtube numbers
and then send them your special they'll
buy it they're just
they're just business people there's
their suits yeah they just want numbers
they want money they want views so uh if
you don't want to do it the long way
that's your route go viral
then do comedy